forecasters are warning more than 32
million Americans to watch out for
severe weather today in the southern
plains meteorologist Megan Glaros of our
Chicago station wbbm-tv is tracking what
could happen over the next few days
Megan when I saw you when you were in
town today I thought rut row so going
down something's gonna happen and Gale
what I'm concerned about at this point
is that we're setting up for a multi-day
severe weather event because of a strong
system that's going to be moving through
the area shaded in orange for today
really anywhere from the heart of Texas
stretching all the way up into Kansas
will be our area of concern damaging
winds hail up to baseball-sized within
that hashed area plus a few tornadoes
potentially today now watch as we move
into the afternoon the atmosphere really
starts to bubble up you can see that
intensity of storms look south of Dallas
north of Dallas and then progressing on
off to the east look at Memphis Thursday
morning and that extends all the way up
into the Ohio River Valley concerned
tomorrow we'll shift to a different area
more into the deep south at this point
we're also looking at the potential
tomorrow for more tornado activity that
will be the day where tornadoes large
tornadoes are a much better possibility
and then this storm system works off to
the east coast moving into Friday so a
busy next few days Gale alright we'll be
watching Thank You Megan